i see when we were talking about how
some of these philosophical claims are
volutinous they're bleary they're opaque
dubious you don't know what the heck it
means because there's they're speaking
ambiguously
and then you're saying well i don't know
what it means
i understand what mathematics would mean
if mathematics was fundamental for me
please help clarify for me what the heck
does that mean because to me that's just
equally i can understand the statement
that mathematics describes what we've
seen so far but then to say that
mathematics is what we've seen so far i
don't understand what that is is what is
the mathematics and then when we say
it's a rule what is a rule we can play
that game so can you help me understand
the ontology
um
this is the
so first of all assuming that we're not
worrying here about things like girls in
completeness serum or the other things
about math eating its own tail sure um
um we're not trying to do for example
press burger arithmetic which would
allow you to suit to avoid
girdles that complete the same or
anything um
it's
that's one of the things that i find so
a deep
flaw or attribute to me
is that
the more i can be
[Music]
smashed on my
ass by the universe
realizing that i have been misconstruing
my limitations
for being those of the universe
the more i feel i'm making progress the
more i actu that's my aesthetic
acme
i don't think i can answer your question
and that's to me
and i understand your question and feel
your question
and the fact that i cannot answer it to
me
is a
[Music]
beautiful stunning illustration of the
fact that the
deficiency is in me
it's a feature not a bug
it's a feature not a bug
yup um things like um
i don't know how much you know about
algorithmic information complexities
from no i have a question about that i
would like to get to that later
some of i would think information
complexity
i view it as the most
the only true philosophy metaphysics
and by far the deepest that we've ever
come across
girdle
was
his result was one of the most important
philosophical results
precisely because
to my thinking aesthetically
because it was a
incontrovertible demonstration of how
all that we were so sure
we all thought the same as david hilbert
did
and we were wrong
and whether we can understand it or not
is irrelevant
and this is a similar kind of a thing i
do
feel that question you're asking and the
fact that i don't understand what it
means to give it as an answer
doesn't mean that that conclusion which
is causing that
question of yours that the conclusion is
wrong it's a limitation in me
that i can't grapple with what the
conclusion even means
just like hilbert couldn't grapple with
what girdle meant